maybrit illner und die begrüßt die gäste
dieses abends ausgesprochen herzlich und
wir fangen mit der aktualität an und die
ist nicht schön zwei terroranschläge 13
schläge heute abend in afghanistan in
kabul herr merz mit toten zu beklagen
die bundeswehr hat die deutsche
luftbrücke beendet wer hilft eigentlich
nach dem 31 8 wenn dann auch die
amerikaner raus gehen und vielleicht
auch die franzosen und vielleicht auch
den die briten wer hilft dann eigentlich
den afghanen sind schreckliche bilder
die wir heute abend sehen wir mussten
sie erwarten diese angriffe des
islamischen staates der vermutlich
dahinter steckt sind ja schon seit tagen
gegenstand auch der
medienberichterstattung
diese mission endet in einem vollkommen
desaster schlimmer als das was die
amerikaner 1975 in vietnam erlebt haben
und wir werden lange brauchen um das
aufzuarbeiten und auch die frage zu
beantworten die sie gerade gestellt
haben das kann heute niemand seriös
beantworten ich finde die erste antwort
die man vielleicht geben kann wir
müssten eigentlich in der lage sein in
solchen situationen unsere staatsbürger
aber auch unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten schnell wieder heraus zu holen
und dies auch sicher einen flughafen
abzusichern und es ist eigenartig dass
bürger herausholen das ist eigentlich
das mindeste was eine bundeswehr leisten
können müsste aber das ist nur eine sehr
vorläufige antwort die deutschen
soldaten sollen in sicherheit sein
robert habeck ist bei uns einer der zwei
vorsitzenden der grünen herbeck kann man
nach 20 jahren sagen dieser einsatz war
im grunde ein guter gedanke er sollte
sich vom irak unterscheiden und ein
sogenannter guter einsatz sein und er
endete nur dieses tools oder glauben sie
mit dem blick auf dieses ende dass wir
insgesamt viel vorsichtiger werden
sollten in bezug auf militäreinsätze er
war nicht ehrlich war nicht ehrlich
kommuniziert es war ein krieg von
vornherein ist doch ständig so genannt
wurden nicht so genannt werden sehr
lange nicht und die militärische
niederlage wird jetzt noch überboten
sich eine moralische niederlage in der
tat sowie friedrich merz gesagt hat weil
das ist ein desaster und die menschen
die ihr leben riskiert haben im
vertrauen darauf dass die worte des
westens der usa der nato deutschlands
auch was gelten dass dort
rechtsstaatlichkeit freiheit
zugang zu medien meinungsfreiheit
meinungsäußerungen rechte für frauen und
für mädchen eingeführt werden die sind
jetzt verraten und verkauft doppelt
verraten und verkauft diese einsätze
unter einem grünen außenminister vor 20
jahren und er wurde von den grünen nie
abgelehnt und nie im bundestag bekämpft
als einsatz geht diese moralische
verantwortung auch an sie
ist es jedenfalls so dass in den letzten
20 jahren viel schief gelaufen ist in
den letzten jahren haben wir uns immer
kritisch zu dem einsatz verhalten wobei
sich man darauf auch nicht zurückziehen
darf wir haben jetzt gesehen dass der
überstürzte truppenabzug auf einer in
einer langen kette von fehlern dass die
schluss der schlussakkord war die
schluss kette sozusagen dann geschlossen
hat das war sicherlich in den letzten
monaten der fatale fehler also dass
donald trump nur mit den taliban geredet
hat das hat das signal an die
afghanische armee gesetzt die seit
verraten und verkauft wir gehen da jetzt
raus verlassen euch alleine also auch
der truppenabzug selbst war so wie er
organisiert wurde falsch und ein problem
so dass am ende alles falsch das muss
man so sagen da ist kein erfolg mehr da
und die vor allem die soldaten und
soldatinnen die da gekämpft haben müssen
sich auch im stich gelassen fühlen als
die durch eindeutig torben sind
kameraden verloren haben leid erlebt
haben und leid zugefügt haben auch die
stehen ja jetzt vor dem trauma das alles
umsonst gewesen ist nein das war kein
guter einsatz und es war kein guter
einsatz und die neue kalibrierung der
deutschen außenpolitik muss danach
erfolgen wir werden uns neu fragen
müssen welche interessen wir vertreten
die interessen wir haben welches viele
einsätze haben wie sie beendet werden
wir unsere alliierten sind ob sie
erfolgreich durchgeführt werden können
oder noch vieles mehr dazu kommen wir
noch ich möchte unbedingt dagmar
rosenfeld
grüßen journalisten chefreporterin
redakteurin von der welt die grünen und
die cdu sorgen frau rosenfeld
deutschland und europa müsse weltpolitik
fähig gemacht werden sind wir davon
jahre oder lichtjahre entfernt also
angela merkel ist ja mal die letzte
verteidigerin des westens das war die
new york times hat sie so genannt die
anführerin der freien welt es war der
guardian der sie so genannt hat und wenn
man sich dann mal gestern ihre
regierungserklärung angehört hat zu
diesem afghanistan desaster da muss man
sagen sie ist maßlos überschätzt worden
offenbar weil als erklärung für dieses
desaster einsatz hin zu haben wie im
nachhinein ist man immer klüger zu sagen
wir alle haben uns verschätzt wir haben
die geschwindigkeit unterschätzt also
diese schuld oder verantwortung zu
kollektiven zu internationalisieren das
ist ein bisschen alle haben geirrt und
dann ist eben im nachhinein der irrtum
erscheint als alternativlos das wird dem
was man ihr zugeschrieben hat jedenfalls
nicht gerecht wir gucken auch da nachher
noch nach vorne blamieren sich herr merz
in kabul nicht nur ein außenminister und
eine verteidigungsminister sondern eine
regierung und vielleicht sogar ein
ganzes land ist blamiert sich im grunde
genommen die westliche
staatengemeinschaft
die auch nie sauber analysiert hat was
denn nun eigentlich der sinn und zweck
dieses einsatzes sein sohn aber bleiben
wir doch mal in deutschland über die
staatengemeinschaft kann man natürlich
auch noch reden und was die franzosen
und briten gemacht haben auf jeden fall
haben die schneller ihre leute raus
geholt und die haben auch erst evakuiert
also sie haben es insgesamt klüger
angestellt sagen wir so sie haben den
rücktritt des spd außenministers
gefordert deshalb frage ich danach frau
million karrenbauer müsste die nicht
genauso zurücktreten hatte im kanzleramt
nicht geschlafen wo war die kanzlerin
warum war sie im kino und nicht im
krisenstab müsste man sich diese frage
nicht auch einsteigen also ich finde
dass die erste verantwortung für die
sicherheit des botschaftspersonals beim
außenminister liegt und diese
verantwortung nicht gerecht geworden es
hat ja tage vorher hinweise bitten
gegeben die botschaft zu räumen durch
die nachrichtendienste und der ist dem
nicht gefolgt nun kann man alle
möglichen versäumnisse hier zusätzlich
verständlich machen ja es macht ja dann
keinen sinn im übrigen vier wochen vor
einer bundestagswahl tritt niemand mehr
zurück
es ist auch im grunde genommen
unerheblich entscheidend ist doch was
folgt jetzt daraus würde übrigens gern
auch mal die frage beantwortet wissen
was machen eigentlich russland und china
wie verhalten sich diese beiden länder
eigentlich die beiden botschaften sind
ja nicht geräumt worden sondern im
gegenteil sie sind auf gestoppt worden
also wir stehen hier vor einer wirklich
und robert habeck hat das wie ich finde
richtig gesagt wir stehen vor einer
ganzen neujustierung der deutschen auf
der europäischen außen
sicherheitspolitik und wenn ich europa
sage dann sollten wir endlich aufhören
mal mit diesem gerede über die
europäische armee wir sind ja noch nicht
einmal in der lage eine europäische
außenpolitik konzeptionell zu entwerfen
ich sagen operativ gesehen so mehr da
stehen eine ganze reihe von fragen im
raum die heute auch aus diesen aktuellen
ereignissen daraus gar nicht so schnell
beantwortet werden können das braucht
zwar ist eigentlich die friedrich merz
widersprechen das ist nicht egal was
gewesen ist und jetzt nur nach vorne
gucken braucht eine ganz entschieden
eine aufarbeitung dessen was in den
vergangenen wochen in der
bundesregierung gelaufen ist ein
unterstand werde ich habe gesagt das ist
jetzt egal was mit den personen passiert
dass ich nicht die entscheidenden
faktoren entscheidend ist was und da
sagen sie es richtig was jetzt daraus
konsequenzen gezogen werden müssen dafür
müssen die sache das heißt sie sind auch
für einen untersuchungsausschuss muss
man natürlich auch dass ein
untersuchungsausschuss ist oder ob das
andere gremien sind aber dass das
aufgearbeitet werden muss das ist
verläuft und dass cdu und spd an das
moratorium abgelehnt haben was die
grünen gefordert haben um eben alle
unterlagen inklusive sms & co einsehen
zu hören ist das richtig dass du das
halte ich für richtig dass leidet daten
und kommunikations daten gelöscht werden
die für die spätere
sachverhaltsaufklärung noch notwendig
sind halt ich bin dazu da bleibt also
sind sie für einen löschen sollten die
nationalen daten gelöscht werden oder
auch
kommunikations daten gelöscht werde im
übrigen glaube ich nicht dass es
überhaupt zulässig ist so etwas zu tun
das sind regierungsdokumente und die
werden natürlich für die aufrufe es geht
ja um es ein solcher sei angesetzt sind
es ist tatsächlich irgendwie auch eine
forderung der opposition wenn sie sagen
sie sind dafür und unterstützen ist dass
es dazu nicht kommt das wichtige inhalte
gelöscht werden ist das schon mal eine
gute nachricht dass sie so zögerlich
sind mit der übernahme von verantwortung
herr merz wundert mich ein bisschen weil
man kann ja auch nur in die zukunft mit
einem anderen ziel und mit einer anderen
konsequenz schauen wenn man sagt
menschen müssen auch verantwortlich sein
für das was sie tun und es waren nun
nachgewiesen dass wir viel früher diese
grenze die uns unterstützen unsere
eigenen leute hätten da rausholen können
ja ich sage mal persönliche
verantwortung aus politischen
fehlverhalten zu ziehen ist ja etwas aus
der mode gekommen die einzige die sich
hier wirklich zu ihrer persönlichen
verantwortung bekannt hat aus dem amt
heraus ist annegret kramp karrenbauer
die gesagt hat diese mission ist meine
verantwortung und wenn sie gelingt steht
meine verantwortung auf dem spiel ich
finde das ist aller ehren wert und alles
andere wird man in ruhe bearbeiten
aufarbeiten müssen ich habe nur gesagt
von den personen unabhängig und das ist
jetzt wirklich
zweitrangig entscheidend ist was ist da
eigentlich passiert und was ist da
falsch gelaufen und vor allem was für
schlussfolgerungen ziehen wir daraus für
die zukunft dann ähnliche frage an
robert habeck wie kann es sein dass auch
das kanzleramt offensichtlich nicht
informiert ist das ein innenminister
visa ausstellungen mit listen verfügt
oder besser gesagt diese wiesen gar
nicht zulässt wie kann es sein dass auch
eine bundeskanzlerin im kino ist und
nicht ein krisenstab leitet ich stelle
die gleiche frage nochmal wie geht das
ist das alles irgendwie
den wahnsinn eines tages zuzuschreiben
männer ohne der aufklärung die
tatsächlich erfolgen muss mit gut dass
herr merz gesagt hat die daten müssen
erhalten bleiben vielleicht setzt sich
das ja durch in seiner partei und in der
amtierenden regierung kann man
sicherlich drei sachen schon sagen ohne
dem vorgreifen zu wollen
nachgelagerte dienste und behörden
müssen den regierungsmitgliedern auch
die wahrheit sagen also es darf keinen
kennen atmosphäre entstehen wo man
das verschweigt dass eigentlich die
wirklichkeit ist in dem fach aus an den
gehorsam opportunisten zu berichten er
das auf das muss man dann sozusagen im
detail sich anschauen aber wenn man
jetzt das versagen es gibt nur zwei
möglichkeiten entweder die dienste
wussten ist besser da sagen sie der bnd
es unter haben haben es dann aber nicht
so berichtet dass die regierungs darüber
dann klar entscheiden konnte dann es
gibt dann endet die politische
verantwortung trotzdem nicht beim bnd
sondern ist die pflicht auch von
ministern ministern die leute dazu zu
bringen ihnen die wahrheit zu sagen
damit sie wahrhaftige entscheidungen
treffen können das ist das erste was
aufgeklärt werden muss das zweite das
wird man denke ich sagen dürfen ohne zu
unfällen mit der regierung zu sein der
zustand der verantwortungslosigkeit ist
natürlich grassiert das betrifft jetzt
in diesem fall die verantwortung für die
lage-einschätzung in afghanistan keiner
will es gewesen sein innenministerium
außenministerium
verteidigungsministerium kanzleramt
bären die alle sagen ich nicht schmeißt
die verantwortung findet heiße kartoffel
werk eine regierung wo keiner es gewesen
sein will braucht aber kein mensch also
das privileg einem land zu dienen ist ja
noch immer ein hohes also brauchen wir
ein selbstverständnis das heißt ich will
es immer gewesen sein denn anders kann
es nicht funktionieren das ist
gravierend und das dritte ist das eine
fehlerkultur dann auch zugegeben werden
muss ich finde wenn menschen sagen meine
verantwortung ich bin dafür
verantwortlich dass der lageberichte
nicht überarbeitet wurde aus folgenden
gründen vertrete ich das dann kann man
darüber streiten ob die gründe gut genug
waren oder nicht aber dieses wegducken
aus der verantwortung ist schwer
erträglich ich habe noch eine frage an
der name weg wenn ich über sie reden
über
verantwortung über moralische werte über
diesen einsatz und die verantwortung
dieses landes auch für die menschen in
afghanistan
die linkspartei hat ja gestern dem
einsatz der bundeswehr dem
evakuierungseinsatz hat sie sich
enthalten wenn den grünen diese werte so
viel bedeuten dann müssten sie doch
spätestens seit gestern eine koalition
mit der linken ausschließen ich halte
das für einen fatalen fehler was die
linkspartei gemacht hat denn was sollte
man in dieser situation denn sonst
anderes tun als mit hilfe der bundeswehr
möglichst viele menschenleben zu retten
und deswegen nimmt sich die linkspartei
wenn sie so weitermacht selbst aus dem
spiel der britischen fahren aber dass er
verhandlungsfähig
was die linkspartei ist also kommt gibt
linkspartei für sie als
koalitionspartner in frage ja oder nein
sie ist eine demokratische partei mit
der man sich auseinandersetzen muss mit
der man auch reden kann aber wenn sie
sich so aufstellt ist sie selber nicht
in der lage die regierung zu tragen hier
machen leute mit den fragen zur sache so
schwer das auch fällt aber es geht jetzt
um die menschen und es geht vor allen
dingen um die menschen vor ort wie groß
muss diese große humanitäre geste sein
von der joschka fischer gesprochen hat
und nicht nur ihr gesprochen hatte haben
reden wir über 10.000 menschen über
50.000 menschen wem helfen wir das ist
keine humanitäre geste mit verlaub in
diesem fall ist die sache anders
gelagert als beispielsweise bei dem
krieg in syrien es geht hier um die
menschen deren wir qua den wir quasi ein
wort gegeben haben wenn anstand und
verantwortung und zu seinem wort stehen
irgend etwas bedeutet dann erlischt
unsere verantwortung diesen menschen die
uns geholfen haben die die bundeswehr
der bundeswehr geholfen haben die dafür
gesorgt haben dass ministerin oder
kanzlerin auf truppenbesuch abends beim
zdf im fernsehen zu sehen waren die
liszt nicht weil die truppen abziehen
sondern wir haben eine verpflichtung
irgendwann zu reden mit den
nachbarstaaten zu reden die leute da
rauszukriegen auch über den 31 achten
oder über den heutigen tag hinaus das
hat aber nichts mit humanität zu tun
oder humanitärer größe oder so etwas ist
nicht hilfsbereitschaft es ist
moralische verpflichtung an dieser
stelle diesen menschen konkret gegenüber
die für die investment für uns
gearbeitet der ernte und ihr leben aufs
spiel gesetzt haben um diesem land
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie zu
geben und dann haben wir über das
eingeredet und automatisch sprechen
manche politiker davon dass wir 2015
unbedingt verhindern müssen wir reden
jetzt also auch über eine mögliche
flüchtlingsbewegung die es aus diesem
land geben kann wie wohl man sich das
bizarrerweise jetzt ja überhaupt nicht
vorstellen weil man offensichtlich aus
dem land nicht herauskommt in welcher
größenordnung denken sie
wird deutschland damit menschen aus
afghanistan rechnen lassen die situation
ist mit 2015 überhaupt nicht
vergleichbar wie eben schon hergeleitet
wir haben eine ganz andere moralische
verpflichtung es geht um eine spezifisch
zu definierende gruppe die im vertrauen
auf unser wort gehandelt hat und die
menschen kommen nicht raus ich höre auch
dass der kabuler flughafen im grunde
demoliert wird gerade ich bin mal
gespannt ob danach er zivil genutzt
werden kann die nachbarstaaten machen
die grenzen dicht das einzige was mir
2015 vielleicht vergleichbar ist ist die
komplett mangelnde vorbereitung der
bundesregierung das ändert sich in der
tat ansonsten sind die beiden
situationen jeweils einzeln zu
betrachten also die kraft der
differenzierung sollte politik schon
immer noch aufbringen es werden bemerken
sie jetzt wie schnell dieses wort oder
diese jahreszahl 2015 in der runde war
obwohl es eigentlich bisher überhaupt
keinen anlass gibt darauf zu spekulieren
glauben sie dass diese immigration noch
ein wahlkampfthema wird frau rosenfeld
oder sagen sie ist übrig sich in den
nächsten vier wochen das thema glaube
dass die migration kein thema in diesem
wahlkampf sein wird und 2015 also ist ja
bezeichnend der weise waren es alles
unions-politiker von julia klöckner über
markus söder armin laschet
die die diesen satz nach dem fall von
kabul sofort ins spiel brachten 2015
darf sich nicht wiederholen
und da ist schon mein eindruck dass es
da mehr um ein trauma der partei geht
und dass so was wie eine selbst
beschwörung gewesen ist als um eine
tatsächliche herausforderung weil es ist
ja nun mal so das problem ist ja nicht
menschen einzulassen sondern das problem
ist im moment die menschen aus
afghanistan raus zu holen herfried
münkler hat es auch gesagt heute in
einem interview mit christ und welt herr
merz würden sie sagen auch diese 10.000
bis 50.000 da gibt es verschiedene
zahlen menschen die uns geholfen haben
im land sind natürlich unbedingt durch
uns mit allen mitteln aus afghanistan zu
holen oder machen sie dann fragezeichen
da gar kein fragezeichen dahin wir
müssten das versuchen aber die
realistische chance dass das gelingt
sinkt von stunde zu stunde und deswegen
habe ich eben gesagt wir müssten doch
eigentlich in der lage sein mal mit
unseren streitkräften einen flughafen
abzusichern und die zugänge zu einem
flughafen zu regeln und linken auf
erkämpft so aber wenn der idee aber ich
sag mal ja es ist müßig darüber zu
diskutieren das ist jetzt passiert aber
wir dürfen glaube ich auch jetzt hier
nicht von falschen erwartungen ausgehen
da reden wir über viele tausend menschen
die da betroffen sind auch solche die
vor vielen jahren geholfen haben wir an
dieser einsatz dauert jetzt 20 jahre da
ist ja nun eine ganze generation von
menschen groß geworden die deutschland
hier und in und den nato-truppen
geholfen hat also machen wir es mal
realistisch wenn jetzt auch dieser
flughafen praktisch außer betrieb geht
dann sind die möglichkeiten diese
menschen da rauszuholen sehr begrenzt
und sehr viele möglichkeiten mehr als
die die wir jetzt angewendet haben und
die wir in den letzten tagen gesehen
haben haben wir nicht also das ist eine
bittere aber glaube ich realistische und
notwendige kenntnis haben sie eine
erklärung dafür warum armin laschet das
mit 2015 sofort vergleich wir kennen
alle noch die sätze von haus seehofer
und natürlich auch von ihnen und von
anderen in dieser zeit glauben sie dass
wir überfordert werden könnten neuerlich
mit flüchtlingen zum augenlider weil ich
die einschätzung von von rosenfeld wir
haben die situation nicht und es ist
auch unwahrscheinlich dass sie in den
nächsten wochen oder monaten eintritt
und insofern die vergleiche sind immer
etwas gewagt und etwas mit verschiedenen
sachverhalten unterlegt insofern
wir haben im augenblick keine
veranlassung über eine neue
flüchtlingswelle in deutschland zu
diskutieren im gegenteil wir haben
anlass genug zu fragen was ist da
eigentlich passiert wie können wir da
noch helfen und wo enden da auch
objektiv unsere möglichkeiten wir sehen
und merken nicht nur in dieser frage das
ist tatsächlich auch große politiker
braucht denn die probleme sind groß und
die krisen die zu lösen sind sind groß
und
wir schauen mal auf die politischen
angebote die der wähler hat viele bilder
das hatte ich schon gesagt sind
überzeugt dass dann ausgerechnet bei
grünen und der union man sich für die
zweitbesten kandidaten entschieden hat
und wir schauen mal auf die letzte
umfrage die union betreffend armin
laschet und markus
schlechte werte für armin laschet nur 23
prozent der eigenen anhängerinnen und
anhänger wollen ihn noch als
kanzlerkandidaten 70 prozent wünschen
sich markus söder
ist das reparabel herr merz ja
also wir haben eine schwierige
ausgangslage aber wir haben schon
häufiger in bundestagswahlen vor
schwierigen ausgangslage gestanden bin
mir sicher dass wir es schaffen können
bis zur bundestagswahl am 26 september
stärkste fraktion im deutschen bundestag
zu werden ich traue auch im übrigen den
zahlen die wir da augenblick sehen nicht
wirklich glaube ansbach liegt da näher
dran als die anderen forschungsfragen
aber gut ich gucke auch nicht jeden tag
auf meinungsumfragen ich mache bei mir
zu hause meinen wahlkampf
40 wahlkreisen auch außerhalb meines
eigenen alten
leuten aus der uni oder der
entscheidende punkte design wählen die
menschen in deutschland zu einer
relativen mehrheit die cdu und die csu
da steht ja armin laschet nur zum teil
auf dem stimmzettel im größten
bundesland olaf scholz in einem der
kleinsten annalena baerbock auch also am
ende des tages wählen die menschen ja
auch parteien parteien sind mehr als nur
die spitzenkandidaten also ich bin da
zuversichtlich dass das gelingt und wie
gesagt wenn wir stärkste fraktion werden
im deutschen bundestag dann haben wir
den auftrag zur bildung einer regierung
ausgerechnet markus söder sieht sich
selbst als große antreiber dieses
wahlkampfes unter hören wir noch mal
auch ganz kurz in ihn rein
es herrscht in der union eine große
unruhe lasst uns endlich vernünftigen
wahlkampf machen das ist ganz wichtig
dass es nicht nur darum geht sich mit
schlafwagen ins kanzleramt zu fahren die
verantwortung für die umfragen liegt
nicht in bayern in bayern hätten wir
vielleicht ein besseres ergebnis
erzielen können wäre ich kanzler
kandidat geworden
ja warum empfinden sie dieselben gut
gemeinten ratschläge herr merz als
schläge na ja also es sind ja teilweise
schon etwas ältere zitate die sie da
gebracht sie sind nicht von heute also
der schlaf fragen ist schon mindestens
vier wochen ein bisschen älter aber
in unseren zeiten sind vier wochen
ziemlich
also gerade erst mal ermahnt und das
werden sie nicht einfach so gemacht
haben nein ich habe auf nachfrage gesagt
jetzt muss man zusammenhalten und müssen
zusammenstehen diesen wahlkampf
gemeinsam machen wir machen das und wir
machen das auch in großer
geschlossenheit wissen dass die lage
schwierig ist aber wir stehen ja auch in
einer tiefen zäsur wir sind in sehr
unsicheren zeiten die menschen suchen
antworten wir wissen dass wir jetzt
einen regierungswechsel haben in
deutschland das ist seit 16 jahren das
erste mal sicher das ist einen
regierungswechsel und länder warum
sabotiert markus söder den wahlkampf von
ami also das gegenteil ist richtig
freuen der markus söder macht wahlkampf
wie kaum ein zweiter in der union
und sie in seinen terminkalender schauen
sie in sachen wahlkampf und zwar für
armin laschet und für die cdu er für die
csu in bayern und warten wir es mal ab
es ist genau in einem monat heute und
ein monat ist für einen guten wahlkampf
eine gute zeit und das meinen sie
wirklich ernst wenn ich sage
wir gehen mal zu den grünen habe ich sie
spielen um platz 3 momentan war das
irgendwie noch vor drei monaten absehbar
und spielen genauso platz eins für die
anderen klang moment liegen wir zwei
tore hinten aber aber nicht weil der
märz vier wochen ist eine lange zeit die
super lange nicht wir sind immer in der
lage in steilen pass aus der tiefe des
raumes nach vorne
dreht sich das ist komisch dass man
jetzt wie dieses anfang muss diese
geschichte mit den diesem saarland habe
ich auch immer noch nicht verstanden
also da ist keine gültige liste zustande
gekommen und man hat lieber keinen
spitzenkandidaten als einen man
natürlich nicht das hat sich auch
niemand gewünscht das ist unser eigenes
debakel er also da kann man lange
darüber reden wie das da hingekommen ist
aber ein debakel ist es ohne frage
und da
bin ich eben schon über verantwortung
gesprochen habe da muss sich der
bundesvorstand selbst eben auch in die
pflicht nehmen auch wenn man unmittelbar
natürlich nicht ich nicht im saarland
gelebt habe aber wir haben als
bundesvorstand eine verantwortung
ihrer partei maximal hersteller weiter
wenn man ein bundesland die grünen nicht
wählen kann ist dass zumindest in der
schon mal durchbrochen also das ist ein
großer scheibenkleister und das haben
sie flott formuliert dass herr merz fand
übrigens dass sie als kanzlerkandidat
überhaupt nicht infrage kommen oder
sagen wir wenigstens für ihn nicht in
frage kommen wissen sie das noch
robert habeck hat einfach zu viele
wissenslücken ich war mir deshalb sicher
dass annalena baerbock nominiert wird
sie ist fleißig und medial präsent aber
die mangelnde berufs und
regierungserfahrung spricht gegen sie es
war aus dem april braucht man als
spitzenpolitiker manchmal mut zur lücke
ich glaube dass twitter nicht das
geeignete medium ist dass politiker sich
dauernd euch sagen ich weiß nicht wie
der mehrzahl jetzt drauf guckt aber
ich glaube viele würden durch wünschen
mal in tweets nicht abgesetzt zu haben
märz wollen sie sich zu dieser äußerung
äußern braucht man irgendwie mit blick
jetzt auf die grünen-spitzenkandidatin
vielleicht 90 von ihnen oder also neue
minister mal ging es den grünen
vermutlich heute besser wenn robert habe
kanzlerkandidat geworden wäre insofern
also war zumindestens diese einschätzung
im hinblick auf die performance der
spitzenkandidatin falsch aber gut das
ist so doch da kann es noch
veränderungen geben also wir sind wie
gesagt am anfang der letzten phase des
wahlkampfes und der entscheidung ging es
der cdu auch besser wenn die frage war
markus söder geht ja nicht aber
das ist eine reine spekulation darüber
brauchen wir nicht lange nachzudenken es
ist anders entschieden es ist anders
entschieden und darunter leiden sie
offensichtlich aber nicht mehr so viel
wie markus söder also sie sehen mich
hier nicht leidend sondern sie sehen
mich kampf
entschlossen und auch zuversichtlich
dass uns das gelingt und das ist nicht
aufgesetzt sondern das ist so gemeint
wie ich es sage ich habe genug erfahrung
wie wahlkämpfe laufen und wie
kurzfristig auch wahlkämpfe entschieden
werden können wir haben dieses jahr eine
relativ frühe und lange briefwahl phase
das macht die sache vielleicht ein
bisschen schwieriger noch aber es wird
am ende abgerechnet und nicht einen
monat vorher so und dass armin laschet
kein team festlegt und nicht sagen kann
wer in seinem team ist das hat damit zu
tun dass er dann erklären müsste das
peter altmaier und frau carlitscheck und
herscheid fleckner da nicht drin sind
also ich bin nicht der pressesprecher
von amina schritt dann müssen sie in
frankreich hat bestimmte entscheidungen
getroffen es wird jetzt auch noch das
ist kein team geht ist es so wichtig
dass sie reden so nein das ist ich nehme
ich hab das ja nur beschrieben und es
wird trotzdem im laufe der nächsten tage
und wochen noch das ein oder andere
geben was auch noch mal klarmacht dass
armin laschet ein guter kanzler
kandidaten ist und ein guter kanzler
wird und dann auch vielleicht das eine
oder andere gesicht noch hinzukommt frau
rosenfeld
so viele eigentore
so viele eigentore eben diesen letzten
wochen gab es dann eigentlich nur noch
bei der fußball wm haben sie das gefühl
dass annalena baerbock und armin laschet
wirklich ins kanzleramt wollen also ihre
parteien wollen ins kanzleramt und
ich teile die meinung dass die parteien
beide nicht unbedingt die
gefragtesten kandidaten aufgestellt
haben muss man sozusagen und also das
größte problem der union im moment ist
ihr kanzlerkandidat armin laschet und
das zweitgrößte problem der union ist
der mann der gerne kanzler kandidat
geworden wäre und das nicht durfte und
das nicht verwunden hat und der stellt
sich hinter also da stellt sich hinter
armin laschet und meint dann mit ihm
eigentlich in den rücken zu fallen und
das ist ein gebaren was die union da
gerade an den tag legt das war früher
mal bei der spd so also wie ein den
eigenen kandidaten
und sich möglichst vielen mit mit sich
selbst beschäftigen
und das kommt beim wähler nicht an also
von martin schulz gibt es den berühmten
satz hast du scheiße am fuß haste
scheiße am schuh und das passiert gerade
der union und bei den grünen ist es so
die ambitionen sind da aber ich habe
jetzt das erste mal gedacht vielleicht
hat man parteiintern das kanzleramt doch
schon aufgegeben als man jetzt gesagt
hat dass man ein klimaministerium
gründen möchte mit vetorechten das ist
ja quasi so ein neben kanzleramt und
wenn man selber im kanzleramt sitzt dann
braucht man kein neben kanzleramt und
insofern ist das vielleicht schon
sozusagen der
vorausschauende plan für die niederlage
der mit so einem klima ministerium dann
eingepreist weil sich der kunde gleich
ich wollte noch mal nachfragen zur union
was glauben sie macht das beim wähler
aus dass es bis zur letzten minute oder
sagen wir bis vier wochen vor der
letzten minute eben immer noch diesen
streits um die unterstützung oder eine
halbe unterstützung oder eine mehrfach
bewerbung um diesen job gibt was macht
der wähler oder wo eine partei die mit
sich beschäftigt ist die suggeriert dem
wähler dass sie für ihn wenig zeit und
wenig raum hat und es ist ja noch viel
mehr also union also cdu und csu
streiten darüber was überhaupt in ihrem
wahlprogramm steht also die einen sagen
steuererleichterungen die andere sagt da
steht gar nichts über steuern drin die
einen sagen kohleausstieg 2008 30 die
cdu die csu sagt da muss man schon früh
heraus solche sachen sind nicht
gerade
wahlkampf fördernd oder stimmen fördernd
und dann auch armin laschet ist halt
jemand der fettnäpfchen nicht unbedingt
immer ausweicht und offenbar gibt es
auch im team drumherum niemanden der ihn
vor diesen fettnäpfchen sie war bewahrt
und die union hat halt unter 16 jahren
merkel hat man eben also der sinn und
zweck der union aus eigener perspektive
ist das kanzleramt das ging mit der
person merkel immer ganz gut weil hinter
dieser personen die verschwommenen
inhalte nicht so aufgefallen sind jetzt
ist merkel weg und jetzt steht mit armin
laschet das muss man schon
eine person zur wahl die nicht genug
kontur hat um die konturlosigkeit der
union zu kaschieren zu überdecken
und wenn herr merz frau rosenfeld zuhört
was denken sie wir stehen natürlich
darüber nach was sie sagt
aber da ist natürlich insofern etwas
dran weil 16 jahre im kanzleramt
haben spuren hinterlassen in der partei
das ist ja auch im regierungsalltag
nicht so ganz einfach daneben eine
politische partei zu etablieren und dann
auch für die zukunft wirklich gut
vorzubereiten dass da sind viele dinge
nachzuholen gewesen jetzt muss man
einfach mal sagen es keine
entschuldigung aber wenigsten erklärung
wir sind natürlich durch die
einschränkungen der korona pandemie
stark zurückgeworfen wir hatten
eigentlich vor dem letzten jahren
grundsatzprogramm zu diskutieren und zu
verabschieden das ist nicht gelungen aus
corinna gründen bei den grünen haben es
gemacht ja sie haben es gemacht sie
haben es aber auch in der opposition
vorbereitet das leichter als in der
regierung da sind die kräfte doch anders
gebunden das ist nur eine erklärung
keine entschuldigung richtig gute
erklärung ist es nicht vielleicht
relativiert die frage mal zurück ich
verspreche dass ich sie am ende nochmal
stelle und wir befassen uns jetzt
einfach mal mit diesem wahlprogramm das
kann ja durchaus sinn machen und wir
gucken uns mal an nachdem wir gefragt
haben haben wir die richtigen köpfe für
das was da am 26.9 passiert auch eine
nicht ganz unwichtige frage haben wir
für die zeit nach dieser wahl dann
eigentlich hinreichend geld um wirklich
große dinge in diesem land zu bewegen
und das fragen wir zunächst nicht uns
sondern jemanden den ich sehr herzlich
begrüßte professor achim truger nämlich
er ist mitglied des
sachverständigenrates der
bundesregierung ein wirtschaftsweiser
deutschland hat herr truger korrigieren
sie mich 650 milliarden euro schulden
gemacht in der korona krise für den
umbau zu einem zur klimaneutralität
bräuchte man noch viele milliarden
wie viel finanziellen spielraum hat
diese regierung eigentlich wenn sie denn
irgendwie zustande kommt wie viel geld
ist in der kasse und haben frau illner
die herausforderungen sind natürlich
groß das ist klar und
die korona krise hat erstmal natürlich
große lücken in den haushalten und der
planungen hinterlassen das ist klar wenn
die wirtschaft wirklich brutal abstürzt
wie das der fall gewesen ist und der
staat anhalt einspringt dass der riesen
defizite sich auf sich bilden und mit
der erholenden konjunktur wird jetzt
sozusagen die lücke kleiner aber in
allen planungen bei bund ländern
kommunen ist natürlich die lücke zu der
planung vor der krise nach wie vor groß
und wenn 2023 die schuldenbremse beim
bund wieder greifen soll bei den ländern
ist es kompliziert weil es ja wir haben
16 verschiedene schuldenbremsen noch bei
den ländern da ist es sind
unterschiedlich aber da sind im grunde
genommen die herausforderung ähnlich und
das heißt dass der reifen soll ab 23
genau das sind die spielräume gering
dann sind die geringer märz sie wollen
schulden abbauen und gleichzeitig
investieren und das mit schuldenbremse
mit angezogener schuldenbremse die
schuldenbremse steht im grundgesetz im
übrigen haben wir auch einen
stabilitäts- und wachstumspakt der
europäischen union wir haben einen
maastricht-vertrag der uns verpflichtet
von dem ich hoffe dass er bestand hat
spricht übrigens außer uns in
deutschland niemand darüber und
sozialdemokraten richtig erholen nicht
also wollen sie aufheben nicht sie
wollen die schuld ganz europa spricht
ärgern ganz einfach weiß dass der masse
ja tag europa knie bild und fesselt und
und vom wirtschaftlichen wachstum der
welt abkoppeln wird also gleich gerne
minister alle regierungsvertreter
machten sich da sein denn dann sind wir
die letzten die daran festhalten dass
man die voraussetzung und die bedingung
für den eintritt in den euro war also
ich halte daran fest und meine partei
auch
und das wird möglicherweise ein ziemlich
großer konflikt nach den bundestag jetzt
kommt wieder ein name den wir schon ein
paar mal im mund hatten markus söder
verfolgt verfolgt offensichtlich einen
vollständig anderen plan er hat
zumindest eine tür geöffnet letzte
regierungserklärung markus söder
nachhaltigkeit ist nicht nur eine frage
der ökologie sondern auch der
finanziellen seriosität deswegen sollten
wir auch überlegen generell in
deutschlands top- der klimaschutz als
daueraufgabe mit oder in welcher form er
mit der schuldenbremse vereinbar ist
aber einfach aussetzen geht nicht das
muss verfassungsrechtlich geklärt so da
hat er schon mal auf jeden fall die tür
geöffnet kann sich ganz konkrete frage
der wähler also darauf einstellen dass
mit der union in der regierung die
schuldenbremse doch geöffnet wird wenn
nötig also
gerade klar und deutlich gesagt
aussetzen geht nicht aussitzen oder
aussetzen geht nicht so und damit ist
doch die frage beantwortet und dann
hören ihnen offensichtlich viele
missverstanden er habe ich sie haben
markus söder ausgesprochen gelobt für
diese regierungserklärung und gesagt er
hat offensichtlich verstanden wie
notwendig es ist dass wir einen
investitionsschub haben ich spüre noch
einmal kurz zurück zu dem was achim
truger gerade ausgeführt hat wir werden
geld in die hand nehmen müssen oder es
passiert nichts das ist nicht so schwer
zu verstehen irgendjemand wird den umbau
der wirtschaft aber auch dass der
archive wohn und wie wir uns fortbewegen
bezahlen müssen entweder jeder für sich
jedes unternehmen für sich oder wir
nutzen die kraft der solidarität die
gute bonität die deutschland im moment
hat liegt ja im kern daran dass alle so
fleißig arbeiten dass wir so eine starke
wirtschaft haben und zu treue
staatsbürger sind deswegen werden wir an
den märkten als staat der staat da sind
wir letztlich wir alle der staat ist ja
nicht irgendwie ein fernes gespinst von
irgendwelchen kleptokraten wie christian
lindner erst mal gesagt hat das sind wir
wir belohnen und sozusagen in der
gemeinschaft und wie belohnen wir uns in
dem wir uns mit der wirklichkeit
auseinandersetzen ähnlich wie wir es bei
afghanistan hat der wirklich da ja und
die wirklichkeit so aus und das ist der
unterschied zu der situation von vor
zehn jahren das damals die zinsen auf
kredite sehr hoch waren
und heute sind sie 0 oder negativ das
heißt wenn man sich heute geld leiht
zahlt man weniger zurück der staat das
können privatpersonen nicht machen
weniger zurück als man aufgenommen haben
lässt man dieses geld für 10 420 für 30
jahre wirtschaftlich arbeiten schafft
man wachstum wie darf ich sagen ich
finde bei den grünen ich rede davon dass
wir einen wachstumsimpuls setzen dieses
land nach vorne bringt der dafür sorgt
dass die technischen innovationen hier
mal wieder stattfinden und nicht nur in
china und in den usa was wir so
wohlstand generieren und
klimaneutralität generieren das schafft
dann wertschöpfungsketten arbeitsplätze
die leute zahlen steuern dann zahlen wir
weniger geld zurück als wir aufgenommen
haben und sieht ein reicheres land wir
werden 2050 weniger schulden haben oder
jedenfalls keine höheren schulden als
wenn wir es nicht täten jetzt geld in
die hand zu nehmen weil wir weniger
wachstum generieren würden und wir
werden trotzdem ein reicheres land sein
das ist das worüber wir reden und die
antwort unsere lösung unser vorschlag
ist dass wir die schuldenbremse
beibehalten ich will nicht zurück zu vor
der schuldenbremse aber da irgendwie
schuldenbremse eine logik einführen eine
weitere regel eine erweiterung der
schuldenbremse die sagt das was neues
vermögen aufbaut also neue werte des
staates neue infrastruktur
neue wirtschaftliche prosperität schafft
das was du sagen auch ein vermögen ist
das da finanziert werden und das wissen
sie investitionsfonds und lernen
rezessions regel also der staat wird
angehalten nicht nur den haushalt zu
konsolidieren sondern auch die
öffentlichen vermögen unserer gebäude
die schon entschieden infrastruktur das
glasfasernetz und so weiter ebenfalls
auszubauen zu erhalten und das ist ja
was werd ich meine man kann das ja auch
private übertragen was nützt ein volles
sparbuch von einem das dach einfällt
dann wird man ja immer sagen eine
renoviert million wird das dach ist ja
auch was wert buchstäblich was wert für
die öffentliche hand gilt es scheinbar
nicht so gibt zwei widerworte erstens es
ist ganz schön wenn der finanzminister
wenig zinsen zahlen muss der sparer
bekommt übrigens wenig zinsen es gibt
eine ganz phänomenale große kalte
enteignung sagt man dazu das heißt die
menschen haben natürlich das gefühl dass
ihnen nicht etwas geschenkt wird sondern
geld genommen hat aber das ist die
antwort darauf die ich gerade gegeben
habe die zu niedrigen zinsen sind
ausdruck dessen dass wir eine wachstum
welche in europa haben habe ich das
heißt die zentralbank ist genötigt damit
das geld im umlauf bleibt immer das geld
billiger zu machen günstiger zu machen
die möglichkeit kredite zu nehmen immer
weiter zu senken oder gesenkt zu haben
hätten wir mehr wachstum hätten wir mehr
nachfrage hätten wir mehr beschäftigung
würde dann auch irgendwann der zins
wieder steigen das heißt es ist genau
andersherum das was sie gerade zitiert
haben ist ein missverständnis dessen
warum jetzt hin zu niedrig ist in einer
wirtschaft muss geld ausgegeben werden
wenn alle sparen hat man eine
wirtschaftskrise absolventen aber alle
sparen die unternehmen halten das geld
zurück weil der staat seine öffentlichen
ausgaben nicht ausreichend nachkommt die
privatperson sparen weil die weil wir
länger leben und man unsicherheit hat
wie die rente sein wird und wenn dann
auch noch der staat spart dann haben wir
die wirtschaftskrise also ist der grund
für den niedrigen zinssatz fehlendes
wirtschaftliches wachstum würden wir mit
den investitionen wachstum anheizen die
unternehmen würden die portmonees auch
auf machen sie sind ja immer nur zulagen
die wir gehen der staat schafft
arbeitsplätze wir würden wachstum
schaffen würden auch die zinsen
langfristig wieder steigen wir fragen
bei herrn truger nachrücker die grünen
wollen wenn ich das richtig verstehe
zwischen guten und schlechten schulden
unterscheiden die schuldenbremse soll
eigentlich eingehalten werden er soll
aber zusätzlich noch die möglichkeit
geben zu investieren wir haben also
einen alten deckel und wir finden einen
neuen deckel und haben die alten
schulden aber noch nicht zurückbezahlt
kann man ich hoffe das bild geht
einigermaßen wenn nicht korrigieren sie
mich gleich kann man das einfach tun
kann man zwischen guten schulden und
schlechten schulden unterscheiden
zurückgezahlt werden müssen beide oder
ja natürlich musste zurückgezahlt werden
bzw die schultern müssen heute bedient
werden
die regel die arbeit beschreibt ist ja
eigentlich keine keine neue idee sondern
das ist eine traditionelle
finanzwissenschaftliche regel die
goldene regel der öffentlichen
investitionen und die logik ist im
grunde wie beschrieben jetzt kann man
streiten wie genau grenzt man die
investitionen ab
und das mag manchmal
vielleicht etwas schwierig sein aber man
kann beispielsweise auf die ganz normale
statistik zurückgreifen die in europa
von eur statt angewendet wird dass das
eine klare definition
und der vorschlag ist tatsächlich
ja im grunde genommen lehnt sich an das
was lange zeit in den
finanzwissenschaftlichen lehrbüchern
stand ich halte es für plausibel und
ich würden sagen das kann man machen
interessanterweise herr merz ich fragte
jetzt erstmal sie haben die union setzt
ja darauf oft aus den schulden
herauszuwachsen sie gehen davon aus dass
diese schuldenbremse nicht über gebühr
strapaziert werden muss und dass es
gelingen kann all das was vor diesem
land steht klimaneutralität große
revolution eigentlich großer riesiger
umbau dass das schaffen dass wir das
schaffen indem wir
es heraus wachsen indem sie aus den
schulden heraus waren sie vorher bevor
ich darauf antworten muss man doch zudem
etwas sagen was er arbeite gerade gesagt
hat unser leben ist denn das sparbuch
das volle sparbuch des staates der jetzt
das dach reparieren muss der staat hat
kein volles schlag sparbuch wir haben
schulden und zwar in großer zahl im
übrigen habe ich diese zinsen sind nicht
ausdruck der wachstumsschwäche wir haben
vor corinna zehn jahre das
wachstumsstärkste jahrzehnt in europa in
der welt gehabt dass wir überhaupt seit
dem neunzehnten jahrhundert gehabt haben
wenn das richtig wäre was sie gerade
sagen dann hätten wir die höchsten
zinsen aller zeiten haben müssen die
zinsen sind niedrig wegen der ezb und
der zentralbankpolitik die übrigens
jetzt in amerika langsam korrigiert wird
die europäische zentralbank hält daran
immer noch fest was ich zunehmend
problematisch sehe obwohl wir
mittlerweile inflationsraten haben wir
haben vier prozent in diesem jahr fünf
prozent im nächsten jahr und wir hätten
eigentlich in ihrer logik richtig wäre
längst schon sehr hohe zinsen haben
müssen das thema wachstum und zinsen hat
mit dem was sie an zusammenhang
hergestellt haben nun gar nichts zu oft
allein da und jetzt noch ein wort zu den
investitionen sie sind eingeladen damit
sie sich streiten sie können
wir sprechen dürfen was er habe gesagt
hat so und dann haben sie gesagt und
dann schafft der staat die arbeitsplätze
der staat schafft überhaupt keine
arbeitsplätze der staat hat einen
beamtenapparat der immer größer wird wir
haben eine bürokratie die immer
schwerfälliger wird die arbeitsplätze
werden in der privatwirtschaft
geschaffen so wir haben privates kapital
in diesem land in sehr großem umfang das
mobilisiert werden könnte für
investitionen der staat hat
investitionsmittel nicht ausgegeben weil
sie einfach nicht ausgegeben werden
können wir haben keine handwerksbetriebe
mehr die das machen wir haben eine
bürokratie die das nicht erlaubt selbst
bei denen von ihnen so geliebten
windrädern brauchen wir drei bis sieben
jahre bis ein denkmal steht da liegt das
eigentliche problem und das müssen wir
lösen wir haben eine
investitionsschwäche nicht mangels geld
sondern haben eine investitionsschwäche
weil dieses land zu langsam zu träge zu
bürokratisch geworden ist und das zu
beheben wäre eigentlich die
vordringliche aufgabe und im nächsten
schritt müsste dafür gesorgt werden dass
das private kapital in diesem land
arbeitsplätze schafft so das passiert
aber nicht weil die unternehmen
mittlerweile angst haben vor dem was
nach diesem 26 september möglicherweise
auf sie zukommt und deswegen bleibe ich
bei meiner meine behauptung das programm
von ihnen atmet auf 137 seiten
staatsgläubigkeit und sie trauen der
privatwirtschaft nichts mehr zu an der
stelle liegt das eigentliche problem das
wir haben und dass es corona nur
verdeckt worden vorher hätten wir
eigentlich schon längst viel weiter sein
müssen wir sind es nicht weil wir diese
schwächen in unserem land